welcome to this video what am i doing
here
just lost like 20 seconds while I was
trying to do something and then the game
started let's see we got an attractive
fence with C 6
yeah well f 4 is the best move I think I
don't really know it though I only know
that is the prescribed booth
and I wonder if he may become player can
play Queen b6 some stage okay this is an
idea that a friend of mine taught me
some time ago when I had this on the
board well afterwards and I'd liked it
too the ideas to play c3 bolstering the
centre maybe yes some good moves at the
moment it looks a bit weird yeah maybe
you should take or deform and go for
some count to play with 95 another
interesting movies t5 didn't do any of
that you know case III at least gives me
the option to recapture with the pawn
and the knight coming to g3 intends to
use their five square
yeah to be honest he's playing a all
those standard schematic normal moves
but I don't really think the they
address the the problems in this
position
Knight h5 is interesting though at least
I was trying to prevent my knight hop to
have five taking down one takes on g3
okay let h5 was interesting
how do I continue Queen e1 g3 maybe hmm
not easy not like em I'm in trouble but
I have many ideas it's not sometimes in
some positions you pretty much know what
to do because there's just one one
obvious plan to follow aha
interesting okay yeah yeah I don't might
the Queen's right I mean I have two
bishops check maybe he gets some
substantial come to play against you for
but don't see it at the moment
maybe could could try a c5 I will see if
I can play it Bishop b5 even which at
least should be something yeah probably
preparing that I want I want some
flexibility with the bishop and I need
to protect the center so that's night f6
is not a problem
yeah he just suffers from lack of space
it's not clear what he should do next
it's still fairly solid though it's not
like he's lost or anything he can play
g6 Bishop g7 and just will hang around
and see if I'm spoiling spoiling my
position which can easily happen if you
don't really time your your porn advance
as well and sorry bit of a sore throat
Ian Knight b6
where do you go c5 not sure okay I'll
just take take more space but don't want
to use so much time yeah oh this is this
is very nice
yeah he needs to get some counterplay
how would you do that an all-night C for
you let's let's just prevent any night C
for move for the moment and then and
then make make more progress that's
before I'm just going to take just gain
even more space now step by step
I have c5 protected the bishop is just
ideal on on f2 and I don't want to see
Bishop d2 as well just just protect
against all activity okay all now c5 is
is an idea but I have Bishop Bishop b5
as as a defense
just a small improving move yeah well I
expected that it's it's hard to to stay
put all the time now I have six wins
material just winning winning in the
night
okay
just before he goes some rogue a five
should it take or is this something
better yeah let's just increase the
pressure or D 5 black resigned Johnny
you really going into this end game here
I think is really debatable before I
think it wasn't so bad I mean black is
fairly solid he can play moving like
that for example so well I can take
cringe III I still prefer white I mean
I'm just the kind of guy who wants to
have the center and the bishops so I
like it the position but it's not it's
not sure well okay maybe maybe this is
possible as well but you need to really
quickly improve on what he what he did I
mean time it did very quickly it got got
critical I don't like d5 really it helps
me to oops
it helps me to gain even more space now
I'm just killing all the counterplay
yeah this is a terrible position I don't
really think if white plays really
really well I think black loses this
it's too much to bishops I have active
roofs and this four against three years
is really strong very difficult very
difficult to defend in a practical game
especially so all right thanks for
watching